by this
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i bring you something
that is near and dear to me something is
fantastic
for my childhood something
that means more to group
based heroes than you think
today i bring you prime one studios
ken the eagle from gachima
now let me let me go back because right
now i'm getting ahead of myself
let me go back and
let me start from the beginning because
it is battle of the planets it is
g-force it is eagle riders
and i know you're saying king how can
one cartoon be so many different things
well syndication
uh and worldwide distribution
can change names because trademarks is
all over the place so when you buy
rights to
uh to air programs sometimes you have to
make alterations
like in battle of the planets
his name is mark it's
not ken so there's a lot of confusion
where it goes to this but
let's start early on 1972
gaichiman was born
so was the king that makes gachiman
48 years old now
top cow got the rights in america
to do the original manga manga
so i would read these
later on but the cartoon came first
so i never got a chance to originally
see
the original gachi mine i got battle of
the planets
and when i got battle of the planets
i thought it was the best uh team
based uh cartoon
you could ever watch they were like
galactic police that were cybernetically
enhanced they were all
orphans a cepha tiny there's five of
them
i might add it's uh mark
jason and this is the battle of the
planet names mark
jason princess
gleep and tiny
and they all have numbers on their chest
so
ken he's the leader well mark he's the
leader
he's number one number two was my
favorite
which was jason the condor he had the
dark
purple suit purplish um purple and black
beautiful stuff they all have different
attributes of birds so there's
uh dove uh eagle a condor
an owl and a a duck
so and they all have different vehicles
he uses a plane mark uses a plane
jason uses a race car uh
princess uses a motorcycle
gleep uses like a little tank and
tiny uses the main uh phoenix ship
and they all the their mantra is
uh five that come together as
one and it was so great because they
will
fight galactor uh he's like
a galactic uh enemy in america he's
called the luminous one
and it it was
so power rangers before
power rangers was power rangers like
they had a little watch and they would
go
eagle go and it would turn into their uh
pesanas beautiful stuff
they could not be beat so one of my best
stories
was a crossover it was
wild storm got together with top cow now
wild storm did thundercats
tactile did battle the planets so that's
why these both
have different titles thundercats and
battle of the planets for wildcat uh uh
wildstorm and top cow did battle of the
planets
and thundercats both of them got equal
billing
in their own perspective books uh
you say um these books
were so fantastic for me
because i i
never thought that both of those
cartoons will merge
you know the underlining story is they
meet on the planet they battle
each other and they realize that they're
fighting for the same team
then they go for the common core uh goal
and
boom at the end there's one
like kiss chatara kissed
um and i believe that was in a wild
storm book
chatara kiss jason the condor
and wiley kitt
or wily cat one of the two well i think
it's why the kid
yeah kiss glee in uh the top cow one
so you know they both ended with a kiss
and i guess that signified something for
the cartoons
now let's get to this magnificent statue
well you have ken the eagle
on a galactic tank
that either he just destroyed
or he helped destroy and he's in the
middle of the base
it has a light up feature the light up
feature
is right here like you can turn it on
and you can turn it off
it's a button that's right next to one
of the galactic warriors heads
and one two three four five light up
points
they light up really uh brightly in the
dark
uh ken is leaping off it with his weapon
in his hand
with his wings extended because they can
glide they can't fly but they can glide
they cybernetically enhance so they're
stronger they're
faster uh than the average
warrior the tank base itself
like you can see the rubble here you can
see the
chain mill going in to the
the gun bay you can see the two turrets
at the top uh
the base is well done you can see
you know the galacture galactor symbol
on the side and it's different shades
that could differ blah different shades
that shows the base is very different
right so you see the metal you see
bullet markings all over the place
you see uh the steel right over here
you can see the armor plating you can
see the fire where it got hit at
and then you get up to the statue
himself where he's leaning off for one
leg
pivoting off with one knee bent the
textures on the pants
is phenomenal you see the belt you see
the the chest piece is an off gray
type of white with gold trim
around it goldish silver's trim
with blue in the heels with the red
now the facial it has two switch out
portraits
the second switch out portrait which i
won't display
is the broken face portrait like he's
in a real battle and it has a switch out
hand
which i won't display that's his uh
his extended hand uh in his waistband
he has his weapon here i will display it
because he's
you know i'm not going to have him with
one weapon i have more too one in his
hand
one in his waistband and you can see the
holder where he has it in his waistband
i mean in his hand
the empty uh holder's hair
they will go into the back this statue
is so phenomenal i waited so long for
the statue
i can't say that i see any flaws in the
statue
because this statue is impeccable
for me so this is the part in the video
where i'm gonna ask you to hit that
not yet like follow subscribe
and hit the joy button hit that joy
button
you know where that joint button is that
join button is right there at the bottom
when you join the room you can see uh
unboxings you can see live unboxings
that i do with dark castle x
uh in midweek right before i do kos
you can see uh old episodes of kos you
can also see
when we go to pax and we go to different
game shows
that you can see all the stuff that the
the lords do we also have a ton of
videos up
go to lordsofgaming.net where we have
i don't know how many writers right now
but gene is putting in that work this is
the second time he won scribe it a month
and that man does impeccable work stick
around
watch the rest of the video where you
can see the statue in all his glory
and watch the unboxing so
i got a statue coming next week and
doing the live unboxing on golf castle x
today at 5 p.m so you will get a preview
of exactly what's coming next stay
[Music]
collected
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
together
[Music]
hey come on
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
let me tonight
[Music]
you look into my eyes
[Music]
you